Yesterday, as Donald Trump was sending tweet
after derange tweet from the White House,
possibly hopped up on the mania caused
by this steroid dexamethasone that is
on to treat Corona virus. Joe Biden went
to Gettysburg, Pennsylvania, and delivered
one of the best political speeches I've seen in
years at minimum. Now, four years, most of the
speeches have been for by Trump. So this bar
was not necessarily high. It's really hard to
care about political speeches when you follow this
stuff so closely the way that I do, because rarely
is anyone's speech particularly good or notable.
But Joe Biden's speech yesterday in Gettysburg
was fantastic. And most importantly, it was
the right speech at the right time. So let's
look at some clips. Here is Joe Biden talking
about the division in the country. Take a look.
There's no more fitting place here today in
Gettysburg to talk about the cost of division,
but how much it has cost America in the
past, but how much it is costing us now
and about why I believe in this moment,
we must come together as a nation.
I have to say, this was a well-written speech,
but it also fits as such a perfect contrast to
Trump's antics. Trump's antics are making it so
easy to write these and to simply be the adult
in the room in comparison to the mess that's going
on. It was a well done speech regardless. But
Donald Trump is really helping Joe Biden here.
Joe Biden going on later in this discussion to
talk about the racial unrest. And again, this is
so politically smart, because when you look at
the top three issues for voters, corona virus, the
economy in light of corona virus and racial unrest
in this country and law enforcement, Trump's
underwater on all three. Trump's approval is
in the toilet on all three. And for Joe Biden
to focus on this is very politically astute.
In recent weeks and months, the country has been
rocked by instances of excessive police force.
Heart wrenching cases of racial injustice
in lives needlessly incenses lost.
By peaceful protesters giving voice to the calls
for justice. By examples of violence and looting
and burning that can not be tolerated. I believe
in law and order. I've never supported defunding
the police. But I also believe injustice is real.
That's a product of a history that goes back 400
years. The moment when black men, women and
children first were brought here in chains.
I do not believe we have to choose between
law and order and racial justice in America.
Joe Biden is simply making a contrast that
actually makes itself. Joe Biden seems competent.
Joe Biden seems stable. He seems like a steady
hand. Period. That is the contrast. And it was so
evident in this speech. Joe Biden going on to talk
about masks. You know, Trump rip it, removing his
mask when he arrived back at the White House in an
Evita like moment that some are calling Covanta,
which is just great. Joe Biden explaining
masks are not political. They're scientific.
Vaccines are not political. They are scientific.
And the big focus on Trump's coronavirus failures
makes perfect sense given the polling.
It's estimated that nearly another 210000
Americans could lose their
lives by the end of the year.
Enough, no more.
Let's just set partizanship aside. Let's
end the politics and follow the science.
Wearing a mask, wearing a mask is not a political
statement. It's a scientific recommendation.
Social distancing isn't a political statement.
It's a scientific recommendation. Testy, Tracy.
The development and all approval and distribution
of vaccine isn't a political statement.
It is a science based decision.
We can't undo what has been done.
We can't go back. We can do so much better.
And, you know, although it hasn't been in the news
as much because of Captain Cauvin catching the
virus, we again had nearly 45000 cases yesterday.
It's building again and it could be getting
much worse as we get to Election Day over
the next 27 days. Joe Biden starting to wind
down the speech with a conciliatory message
that is very much welcome to millions of
Americans are welcomed by millions of Americans.
As president, I will embrace hope, not
fear, peace, not violence, generosity, not
greed and light, not darkness. I'll be a president
who appeals to the best in us, not the worst.
I'll be a president who pushes toward the future,
not one who clings to the past. I'm ready to fight
for you and for our nation every day, without
exception, without reservation, and with the
full devoted heart. We cannot and will not allow
extremists and white supremacists to overturn
the America of Lincoln and Harriet Tubman and
Frederick Douglass and then Biden clarifying.
And again, this is not. It was a very well-written
speech. The concept of a conciliatory message
is not that notable, but because the contrast
is Trump. Joe Biden clarifying he will be
the president for everyone is again a
really great way to draw a contrast.
He's used to work, Joe, but they
can't work that way anymore.
Well, I'm here to tell you, they can and they
must. If we're going to get anything done.
I'm running as a proud Democrat. But I
will govern as an American. President.
I work with Democrats and Republicans. I
work as hard for those who don't support me
as those who do. That's the job of a president.
The duty to care for everyone.
Refusal of Democrats or Republicans
to cooperate with one another
is not due to some mysterious force beyond our
control. It's a decision. It's a choice we make.
And if we can decide not to cooperate,
we can decide to cooperate as well.
Just pitch perfect. Pitch perfect. This is the
message America wants and needs to hear right now.
We have to go in a different direction. What we've
been doing isn't working. It's a complete speech.
It had going. It's like a middle middle school
English, right. It had a beginning, a middle and
an end. It had a logical conclusion that followed
from the premises. It was a clear contrast with a
sort of historic element to it. Biden expressing
a commitment to reuniting a nation that has been
so divided, rightly so. This is not one
of those divisions that is artificial.
Half the country seems unwilling or unable
to realize that we have a president who has
brought the country to the brink,
quite literally. And Joe Biden very
much triggering Donald Trump with this speech
shortly after Biden was done in Pennsylvania.
Remember, the speech was in Gettysburg,
Pennsylvania. Donald Trump tweeted.
How does Biden lead in Pennsylvania
polls when he is against fracking jobs,
Second Amendment and religion? Of course, those
are all lies. Fake polls. Trump says I will win
Pennsylvania. Hopefully not. We're going to talk
about Arizona later. But in the latest polls out
of Pennsylvania, Biden leading by an average of
six point three and by as much as eleven in the
latest Monmouth poll. Biden can win Pennsylvania.
Early voting is happening now in Pennsylvania. It
started weeks ago and runs through October 27.
We have the opportunity. Let's make it happen.
If you were voting already in Pennsylvania
or wherever. Let me know how it's going.